الان مشاهدينا الى فقره التحليل العسكري
مع الزميل جلال واللواء فايز دويري ايمان
ما ذكرتيه الهان هو الابرز وسنعرض بعد
قليل فيديوهات لكمين كتائب القسام وايضا
ما نشرته صه القدس حول استهداف قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في مناطق متفرقه في
قطاع غزه ويعلق عليها اللواء فيز ويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ولكن مباشره
اليك عبد القادر ا طلعنا على اخر التفاصيل
خلال الساعات الماضيه وسير المعارك
والمواجهات نعم جلال ولعلي سانطي الزيتون
الذي يعود الى الواجهه من خلال ما اعلنته
كتائب القسام وبالحديث عن هذه التطورات
هنا في الجبهه الشماليه لطالما كان حي
الزيتون جنوبي مدينه غزه مسرحا لمواجهه
بين المقاومه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ربما ما اعلنه القسام عن
اشتباك هنا في هذه المواقع تحديدا جنوبي
حي الزيتون مع قوه اشتباك مع قوه رجله
اسرائيليه وتمكنه من الاجهاز كما قالت
القسام على عدد من الجنود على مستوى هذا
المحور هنا في في هذه في هذا الموقع اذا
حي الزيتون يعود الى الواجهه من خلال ما
اعلنته القسام كان هناك ايضا اعلان القسام
عن تدميره ل او تلغيمه لفتحت نفقين ظاهره
تلغيم فتحات الانفاق ايضا تابعناها عبر
اكثر من اعلان لكتائب القسام ودوما على
مستوى محور الزيتون ربما هذا التطور ياتي
في ظل هذا الحديث عن اعاده التموضع للقوات
الاسرائيليه وانتشارها وتقليص اعدادها في
المنطقه الشماليه مثل ما اعلنت اعلنه
المتحدث العسكري ونشرته صحيفه الواشنطن
بوست هذه هي التطورات الابرز ربما في
المنطقه الشماليه لكن سرايا القدس ايضا
كانت قد اعلنت ايضا عن استهداف قوه راجله
بدورها في مناطق قالت التقدم دون ان تحدد
المكان في على مستوى على مستوى قطاع غزه
لكن حينما نذهب الى المنطقه الاخرى وهي
المنطقه الوسطى لم تخلو هذه المنطقه ايضا
من عمليه استهداف تابعنا كيف استهدف
الطيران العسكري الاسرائيلي مخيمات سيرات
البريج المغازي ولكن كان هناك قصف مكثف
لمنطقه الزوايده وحينما نتحدث عن الزوايده
نحن نتحدث ربما عن عمليات او تفكير القوات
الاسرائيليه والجيش الاسرائيلي في محاوله
التحرك وقال بان المنطقه الوسطى هي من
مناطق التحرك له خلال هذه المرحله من
الحرب ربما في محاوله
لتطويق منطقه البريج والمغازي كما اشرنا
له في اكثر من مره هذه التطورات تاتي
بينما كانت ايضا كان هناك حديث ولغط كبير
فيما يتعلق بمقتل تسعه ضباط وجنود
اسرائيليين تم الكشف عن استهدافهم من خلال
تفجيرين الاول كان لشاحنه بها ذخائر وقتل
فيها سته جنود اسرائيليين وجرح العشرات
ولكن كان ايضا هناك عبوه ناسفه وضعت في
كمين ثان ان صح القول استهدف جنودا
اسرائيليين في منطقه البريج كان الحديث عن
منطقه البريج التي تعد ايضا من المسارح
مسارح الاشتباك والمواجهات بين القوات
الاسرائيليه والمقاومه منذ منذ اسابيع
ربما نختم بالحديث عن الجبهه الجنوبيه
الجبهه الجنوبيه بدورها شهدت اعلانات
للقسام عن عمليات استهداف ايضا ل
لقوات راجله هنا في
محاور الشرق الشرق وجنوب شرق مدينه قان
يونس تحديدا بني سهيله وايضا على مستوى ال
خزاعه
وهذه هذا المحور الشرقي والجنوب الشرقي ظل
محور اشتباكات بين المقاومه وكتائب القسام
والقوات الاسرائيليه ومما يعكس
ضراوه الاشتباكات هنا كما قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي في اكثر من مره اذا هذه جبهات
ثلاث ولعل الابرز فيها هو ما يحدث في
المنطقه الوسطى ولكن ربما ايضا ما يحدث في
الجنوب وما يحدث في حي الزيتون تحديدا كان
من ابرز التطورات التي لمسناها خلال
الساعات الاخيره وكان مسرحا مهما للاحداث
في بدايه التوغل الاسرائيلي اللواء
الدويري ما هي المعطيات العسكريه التي
تجعل من الكمين كمينا ناجحا كما حصل مع
القسام في ح توفر توفر المعلومات
ومن
ثم وضع الخطه وفي حال الدوريات الكمائن هي
احد انواع الدوريات يطلق عليها في بعض
الادبيات الدوريه الثابته وهي
انواع
قد
يكون منها ما هو ثابت لوقت طويل او لامد
قصير منها ما يغير اماكنه ومنها ما يستخدم
لاستدراج قوات العدو اذا هذا موضوع اخر
لكن الان يعتمد على الهدف ودقه التخطيط
والنزول بالتفاصيل الى ادق التفاصيل حتى
ينجح لماذا لانه في معظم الحالات انت
تتعامل مع قوه مدعمه يتم اسنادها ويمكن
امدادها باي لحظه وانت هنا تعمل ضمن اطار
زمني محدد
وضيق
لا يوجد لديك طرف الوقت ولا يوجد لديك
احتماليه
الخطا في هذا الفيديو يختلف عما شاهدناه
من فيديوهات سابقه لماذا لانه يمثل عمليه
متكامله لفيديوهات الاخرى كنا نشاهد
عمليات انا لا اقلل من قيمتها كنا نشاهد
عمليه قمص بدبابه ميركافا ب تاندم او
بياسين 105 او
الصاق العمل الفدائي او او
شواف فيديوهات عرضت استهداف مباني لكن ان
يتدرج الفيديو بثلاثه اربعه مراحل لا هذا
اول اول فيديو يعرض هذا يعني اذا كان
الفيديو تم جمعه في دقائق فهذه العمليه
اخذت وقت طويل اخذت وقت طويل ووضح ذلك هذا
الكمين
اولا اهم ميت تبع من المنطقه التي نفذ
فيها ونفذ في في منطقه الزيتون هذه
المنطقه دخلتها كانت لا اقول دخلتها لكن
اصبحت على تماس معها قوات جيش الاحتلال في
الاسبوع الاول من العمليه الع صحيح من
الايام الاولى وبالتالي يفترض استنادا الى
تصريحات الجانب جيش الاحتلال انها امنه تم
التغلب على المقاومه ان تظهر المقاومه من
احد الانفاق
وتكون تتشكل من ثلاثه مجموعات لكل مجموعه
واجب من هذه المجموعات
اولا مجموعه الواجب المعنيه بتنفيذ الواجب
مجموعه الاسناد التي تقدم الاسناد ومجموعه
قطع نجدات لقطع
نجدات القوات التي يتم استهدافها الاسرا
اذا قسم الكمين الى
ثلاثه اقسام ثلاثه مجموعات الان نعم
مجموعه تهاجم مجموعه تمد المهاجمين
بالذخيره ومجموعه تقطع الذخيره عن دعنا
نقول مجموعه الواجب وهي المعنيه بتنفيذ
الواجب مجموعه اسناد وهي تقديم الاسناد
الناري المطلوب لمجموعه الواجب ومجموعه
قطع النجدات لمنع وصول اي تعزيزات الى
منطقه الهدف ماذا الذي جرى شاهدنا في
بدايه الفيديو سبعه جنود من جيش الاحتلال
ثلاث ثلاث وبجانبه شخص سابع تم استهدافهم
من مجموعه الاسناد
اول وتم سدادهم
بالقاذف جرح من جرح قتل من قتل هرب من هرب
الى المبنى تدخلت مجموعه الواجب مباشره
وبدات باستخدام الرشاشات والتعامل مع من
هرب الى داخل المبنى يعني الضربه الاولى
بالقذائف من ثم بالرشاش بالرشاشات الان
جاءت سياره همر تحمل مجموعه اسناد اها
للجيش الاسرائيلي نعم الان تدخل تدخل
القسم الثالث او المجموعه الثالثه من
الكمين وهذا يكون تم اختيار مكانه بمنتهى
الدقه مجموعه الاسناد والواجب هناك يجب ان
يكونوا اكثر قربا وامكانيه الرؤيا وتبادل
الرؤيا مجموعه الواجب مجموعه قطع النجدات
لا تختار المكان المسيطر على نقطه ضعف في
طريق ما لابد للجماعات القادمه للتسييس ان
تمر منها فمجرد وصولها الى النقطه القاتله
تم استهدافها بقذيفه وتم اصابه الهدف وبعد
ذلك انسحبت
المجموعه كما خرجت من فتحه
نفق الى اختفت وعادت الى موقعها جاءت لقطه
اكمل الفيديو جاءت لقطه توضح لنا احد
الانفاق لاحظنا احد المقاتلين في بدايه
اللقطه يتعامل مع جهاز دقيق او صغير كانه
يحضر الكبسوله
ومجموعتها من اجل التفجير ثم حمل حقيبته
وسار داخل النفق وكانت اسلاك التفجير
مرئيه خلفه ثم بدا كان انه يختفي عنا هناك
اعتقد انا لانه التصوير لم يكن في تلك
اللقطه واضحا جدا لي
ان
النفق سيكون به انعطاف ماء وضع الحشوه ثم
شاهدنا وميض الانفجار لانه الانفجار عندما
يكون في مكان ضيق و على زاويه انا لا
اشاهد الكتله الناريه كامله وشاهد وميض
الكتله الناريه فبالتالي هذا ما جرى في
الفي يعني الخلاصه هو كمين ناجح بالدرجه
الاولى وغير مسبوق بحسب ما تقول والمعطيات
وما تبع طيب ايضا حصلنا على مشاهد وفيديو
لاستهداف سرايا القدس ايضا لمجموعه من
جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سنتابعها الان
ايضا لاحقا لتعلق عليها اللواء فيز ويري
هذه هي صور لسرايا القدس لمواجهات
مباشره مع جنود الاحتلال لم تذكر المنطقه
تحديدا ولكن بطبيعه
الحال يعني ساحات المواجهه هي كثيره في في
قطاع غزه سواء كان بالشمال او حتى في
الجنوب ما الذي قراته في في هذه الصور
وهذا ال يعني الفيديو التصوير غير واضح لي
جدا بصوره جيده حركه الجنود حركه
المقاتلين هذا هذا مبنى مبنى تحصنت فيه
تحصنت ف مجموعه ال ان تقدم شخصين كما
لاحظت وبالتالي قاموا باستهداف هذه
المجموعه وهذا الامر الاعتيادي عنا عليه
في الفيديوهات سواء القسام او الجهاد
الاسلامي وهو يعني هذا الهدف المتاح والذي
كان بالامكان تصوير لانه هناك العديد من
العمليات لا يتم تصويرها لا يكون لديك
القدره لاجراء عملي التصوير ها هو الان
يتقدم ها هو تي بي جي ها تي بي جي الان
اطلقها على
المبنى سؤال لواء دويري طريقه قتال سرايا
القدس تختلف عن سرا عن القسام لا اقول
تختلف لكن القسام القدرات اكبر يعني
القدرات اكبر الاعداد اكثر التسليح تطور
اكثر يعني القسام تاتي درجه اولى وتاتي
بعدها الجهاد لكن الجهاد ضمن قدراتها خذت
حربين بصوره
مستقله لكن لديها القدره على اطلاق
الصواريخ الان ما نشاهده هو تقريبا حتى
سلاحها يختلف نوعا ما يعني هذه تعطيك
انطباع انها تي بي جي وقد تكون ار بي جي
لانه الشكل ما بين التي بي جي والار بي جي
قريب جدا بالنسبه للخريطه حي الزيتون
وخانيونس يعني منطقتين بعيدتين ان تاتي
هذه الفيديوهات من هاتين المنطقتين هل
هناك دليل لا الان هذا ما اتيح له ان يصور
انا هكذا اقرا يعني لا يعني اقصد الجبهات
مشتعله في حي الزيتون وايضا في في خ
الجبهات مشتعله داخل ال قع كامل انخفضت
وتيره القتال في القاطع الشمالي ا القاطع
الشمالي لانه بسبب اجراءات الانسحاب
وتحدثنا وقلنا بانه سحب الفرقه 162
و256 وتم انسحابهم
وابتعادهم خ الى 10 م داخل داخل غلاف غزه
وتم الابقاء ع على لوائين زائد مجموعتي
نخبه وبالتالي هناك الاشتباكات مطره في
منطقه حي التفاح و والدرج وجبل السيد
بينما اذا اذا وصلنا الى منطقه وادي غزه
جنوبا المنطقه كلها مشتعله الوسط والجنوب
مشعل واضح في في الفقره التحليليه السابقه
تحدثنا عن م قاله وسائل الاعلام بان
استهداف ومقتل تسعه جنود وضباط اسرائيليين
في عربه او شاحنه تنقل ذخيره كان ب قذيفه
من من دبابه هذا اللغط والتساؤلات
رافقت روايه الجيش الاسرائيلي بشان مقتل
تسعه من ضباطه وجنوده واصابه العشرات في
تفجيرين احدهما لشاحنه محمله بذخائر في
البريج واخر بعبوه ناسفه وسط تكتم عن
التفاصيل نستعرض ما حدث في هذا التقريير
وبعده في هذا التقرير عفوا وبعده متابع مع
اللواء
دويري وصفته مصادر اسرائيليه باليوم
الاقصى على الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه
الحرب لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يؤكد بعض
تفاصيل ما حدث الا بعد ساعات الامر تعلق
وفق الجيش الاسرائيلي بمقتل تسعه ضباط
وجنود واصابه اخرين في تفجيرين منفصلين
خلال معارك قطاع غزه في الساعات ال4
الماضيه الهجوم الاول ادى لانفجار شاحنه
محمله بالذخيره وقالت هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه ان سته من العسكريين قضوا
بانفجار الشاحنه التي كانت تحوي مواد
متفجره معده لتدمير انفاق وذلك في البريج
وتحدثت وسائل لام اسرائيليه عن اصابه 30
ضابطا وجنديا في تفجير الشاحنه وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه قالت لاحقا ان تحقيقا
اوليا للجيش اكد ان تفجير شاحنه الذخائر
سببه اطلاق نار من دبابه اسرائيليه اما
التفجير الثاني فتسبب وفق اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي في مقتل خمسه من العسكريين
وكان بعبوه ناسفه بينما قالت مصادر
اسرائيليه سابقا انه استهدف مبنى كان فيه
جنود وسط قطاع غز
[موسيقى]
اذا هذه بحسب الروايه الاسرائيليه من من
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي استهداف الشاحنه
من دبابه ميركافا كيف كيف تقرا هذه
الروايه يعني الان
السؤال مقتل سته من اصل
30 اتحدث عن 30
شخص يعني امر لا ينسجم مع المنطق العسكري
ان يتم تحميل متفجرات ومعها 30 جندي الا
اذا كان من اعطى الامر لا يملك اي اي ع اي
معلومه في العلم العسكري ولكن لناخذ
بالروايه لناخذ بالروايه الان اطلقت
الدبابه قد يكون ذلك لكن هذا يطرح تساؤلات
هذه الشاحنه طبعا الصور التي عرضت هي هي
تمثيل يعني تصوريه اه الان شاحنات الجيش
الاحتلال معروفه
معروفه والان الدبابه يوجد بها اربعه
اطقام اربعه طقمها اربعه اشخاص هذه
الدبابه مزوده بكل انواع التقنيات
والتكنولوجيا ولديها القدره
على جمع المعلومات في قسم منها في قسم
منها
كاميرات الكاميرا التي يحملها امر الدبابه
مربوطه مع الاقمار الصناعيه فبالتالي لديه
قنوات المعلومات التي هي غير متاحه لمعظم
جيوش العالم فكيف صدر
الامر من الامر الى الرامي ب بمايه ه هذا
الهدف الارتباك امام هول ما يحدث لجيش هذا
ما اود الوصول له ان هذا هؤلاء الافراد
مسكونين بالرعب مسكونين بالرعب يعني من
قام بالليل واطلق النار على الجدران واصاب
زملائه ولم يتم محاكمته بسبب ظروفه
النفسيه قبل فتره اسابيع تحدثوا ان
7% يعانوا من امراض نفسيه مستشفيات
المتخصصه في هذا المجال تتحدث عن ارقام
بالالاف من الذين يعانون من الصدمات
النفسيه اذا هل كان الضابط مسكونا بالرعب
هل كان مخلا ولديه صدمه عصبيه قويه ان
يطلق قنار على هدف
واضح بدرجه 100% انه ليس
من ال المقاومه ام يعني هذا يم يشبه تماما
مقتل الثلاث رهائن الذين كانوا يحملوا
الرايه البيضاء ويتحدثوا العبريه ومكتوب
بالعبري ورغم الحكي هذا اطلق النار
عليهم جيش الاحتلال اذا هؤلاء مسكونين
بالرعب وبالتالي اي عندما كنا نقول
يقاتلوا اشباح كان الاشباح سكنت في صدورهم
طيب عندما يرى ال الجيش الاسرائيلي افراد
وضباط الجيش الاسرائيلي وعباره نيران
صديقه رددت كثيرا لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي
منذ بدايه التوغل البري على الاقل في في
قطاع غزه سقط العديد من الجنود واخرها كما
تقول هذه التحقيقات الاوليه في هذه
القذيفه من الميركافا ماذا يشعر العسكري
ما تاثير هذا عليه يعني هو تاثير مرعب في
الب النفسي لكن اود ان اذهب الى نقطه ابعد
قليلا لهذا الجيش لو كان يقاتل جيشا اخر
لانه في في كثير من الحروب تكون الاسلحه
متشابهه الى درجه الى درجه ما الى درجه ما
لو كان هذا الجيش يقاتل جيشا اخر لا
اتفاجا ان يقاتل نفسه بسبب درجه الخوف
والرعب ام في حركه حركه وحده معينه من
نقطه الف الى نقطه باء وتمر من امام موقع
اخر قد ي يعتبرها قوات معاديه ويطلق النار
على الوحدات العائده لنفس الجيش لانه يبدو
مسكون في الرعب يعني كيف لا امر دبابه ان
يطلق النار على سياره وهو يعلم علم اليقين
ان الطرف الاخر ليس لديه هذا النوع من من
الاليات شكرا بانتظار المزيد من الايضاحات
من الجيش الاسرائيلي شكرا لك اللواء فيز
دويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي